[Music]
spirit is the ethical life of a nation
insofar as it is the immediate truth the
individual that is a world it must
advance to the consciousness of what it
is immediately must leave behind it the
beauty of ethical life and by passing
through a series of shapes attained to a
knowledge of itself these shapes however
are distinguished from the previous ones
by the fact that they are real spirits
actualities in the strict meaning of the
word and instead of being shaped merely
a consciousness are shapes of a world
paragraph 441 is among the shorter
paragraphs in this entire section and in
the phenomenology but like many of these
very short paragraphs there's a lot
packed in there that we need to dwell on
and discuss here Hegel is going to be
talking about a process that is
occurring or rather that already has
occurred and which we as the
phenomenological writers along are
observing having taken place in the
development of human culture human
consciousness and he's stressing a point
that is very important to to emphasize
at the beginning of this section I've
already done that a little bit in in
some of the previous discussions of this
this introductory set of paragraphs but
what that that point is is that we've
now moved to a higher level some sort of
transcendence has taken place in moving
from the previous grand scale shapes of
consciousness which are really a whole
bunch of shapes - Dalton consciousness a
sequence of them we've moved up in an
order and now we're at the level of the
real of the veer click of the actual in
a way that we haven't been before so
let's take a look at what what Hegel is
saying here
he begins with this very pregnant
sentence about spirit saying spirit is
the ethical life of a nation a Fulke
and we should we should dwell on that
just for a moment this this word folk
we've we've talked about this before
earlier on in the reason section when we
were discussing you know the the ethical
substance and how that was found in a
folk so we could translate folk as
nation or people or even nationality if
you like and Hegel is
writing at a time when they're there
there really is a question of the the
German folk as a matter of fact you know
one of his predecessors dicta has
written an address to the German nation
Germany is divided into a set of states
some of them quite weak
some of them quite powerful Berlin you
know where Hegel is going to eventually
teach is in in Prussia which is probably
the strongest of the States but Bavaria
is also important
Austria itself is you know this sort of
mixed this mixed community we might say
in terms of ethnicity is is getting
involved of course in in German politics
right and other states have already come
together as as folks the English the the
Swedes were very powerful until the the
the 19th century you know the French the
Spanish you know the Russians they're
they're all coming on scene
and so we could think of it in terms of
nations as what we're understanding you
know in 19th century and 20th century
Europe and then the larger world with
nationalism but you know if we if we
also think about where Hegel is
beginning we are talking about
communities that could be as small as a
Greek city-state in using examples that
are coming from Greek literature ancient
classical Greek literature like
Sophocles Antigone where we're thinking
about the city of Thebes which is a
northern city in in Greece we're talking
about a very small community and there
there were a lot of not quite
necessarily city-states but smaller
communities and it was a question of how
do we how do we understand them where
can an ethical life be
situated a zit leak Asst Laban
can we talk about a community actually
having its own ethical life perhaps at a
certain size it becomes too large for
that perhaps in our own time the
internet helps to mediate that so that
size isn't such of a issue perhaps we
have to think about local communities
all of this is stuff that we can think
about as we're going through this so
spirit is to be found in the ethical
life of the nation and he says in so far
there's an important qualifier right
insofar as it is the immediate truth now
that by itself is a bit of an oxymoron
within the Hegelian way of putting
things because we begin with certainty
and then we move to truth through
mediation right so to talk about
immediate truth already means that
there's a bit of deceptiveness there
whatever is immediate is not entirely
what it when it is supposed to be upon
analysis but what is its immediate truth
here's where it gets really interesting
the individual now notice will the key
thing I've underlined here the
individual as a world the individual
that is a world not the world but a
world
I'm felt right so what do we mean here
well are we talking about what what
Hegel would later call world historical
individuals it could be them or it could
also be people who find themselves drawn
in and assuming in a one side of a
particular shape of consciousness but
the individual as we've seen in the
previous paragraph is no longer totally
detached from the world alienated from
the world the social world that they
belong to within the matrix of the folk
that the community they in a certain way
represent it and this is a what we can
say this is a naive perspective this
is a a beginning place this is not the
finished position that Hegel has worked
out this is where we start from
and so Hegel is going to trace out a
process of development that begins with
what he's calling here the beauty of
ethical life and now that may sound a
little strange as a phrase so let's
think about what what he's talking about
there when you belong to a community for
some brief shining moment and you think
that everything actually does in fact
make sense
even if it's because you're blind to the
social contradictions running throughout
your entire culture or you're unaware of
the history or all these other things
people do have this mindset everything
is great here oh my gosh this is
wonderful that's what he's calling the
beauty of ethical life it's not just
that everything's great I enjoy pleasure
people treat me nice you're able to do
something ethics is a matter of agency
of action and you're able to act in such
a way as to produce beautiful or fine or
noble actions so you know let's say you
belong to a non-profit and you are
helping to save the world by doing this
wonderful task here and you don't really
look into the books or the operations of
the nonprofit because you know once you
start doing that sort of thing
contradictions start arising you start
seeing that your mission and the effects
are not quite adequate to each other or
that a number of the contributions that
come in actually go to paying staffers
and that there's a hierarchical
organization and the people at the top
make a lot of the money right and less
of the people at the bottom who are
supposed to be benefited from it are
getting those benefits
well those you know sorts of things are
there but you can be blind to them you
can just not have thought about them and
so long as you're in that state what
you're doing can seem to you
to be quite beautiful and can seem to
other people so you go out to the bar
and people that what do you do for a
living
oh I help these people by doing oh
you're such a wonderful person I had
something similar to that this is a bit
of a digression but it's a nice example
well I used to teach in a
maximum-security prison that was my
first full-time teaching job and I went
in with you know very few illusions
about it I think some of the other
people who went in thought that they
were you know these wonderful do-gooders
who were you know teaching to the
oppressed and some of that's true right
I mean prisons are in general not well
managed and there's a lot of
vindictiveness going on in the treatment
of prisoners and it varies from state to
state from vo C to DLC so I don't want
to generalize too much but here's where
it got very interesting so I would have
I would be at academic conferences and
you know we have these name tags and
people would look down and they'd see
Ball State at ISP and they'd say oh
what's is P and I'd say Indiana State
Prison and they say oh you teach in a
maximum-security prison and there there
were really three main reactions one one
reaction was you know I'm not going to
talk with this guy because that's not a
real teaching job because those aren't
real people so conversations over that
happens sometimes and then there are the
people who are much more you know
interested in realistic about it and
we'd have a good conversation and then
there were the people who would come out
with these lines like oh my goodness
that is so wonderful that you're doing
this this beautiful service for these
poor oppressed people most of whom are
innocent and you know it would go on and
on and on and on and I I would at first
you know I thought we were having a
genuine conversation and trusted well
it's not really quite like that and some
of them are innocent but most of them
aren't as they'll tell you it actually
teach them and they were interested in
having that conversation they were
interested in there being some sort of
beautiful image that could be regarded
makes perfect sense from a Hegelian
perspective people like that that's what
we would call you know an immediate
truth Hegel thinks that consciousness
must continue to develop so we have
these shapes these Gestalt --an of
consciousness this is a familiar theme
isn't it to everybody who's been reading
the phenomenology and this is ultimately
supposed to culminate in spirits
knowledge and the word here that Hegel
uses is not air kentis or on air kenan
recognition it's this and it's knowledge
of itself we're leading up towards you
know absolute knowledge which is where
the the book culminates so this is
supposed to be the end of the spirit
section and what is happening in the
spirit section is the development of
these shapes of consciousness and
working through them they each one you
know starts out as usual very promising
and then eventually collapses but we
learn something in the process and there
is a transcendence that is occurring
here now here's where it gets
particularly interesting and this is
what I was talking about as the real
core of this this paragraph Hegel says
that by passing through this series of
shapes it attains to a knowledge of
itself these shapes however are
distinguished from the previous ones
what are the previous ones those in the
consciousness self-consciousness and
reason section by what by the fact that
these shapes are real spirits they are
real minds Geist right each one is an
actuality he says actualities in the
strict meaning of the word what is he
contrasting this to instead of being
shapes merely of consciousness so as we
saw in the previous few paragraphs the
earlier portions of the war
we're tracing out dialectical
progression that wasn't actually
situated in a particular life in a real
community I mean it was to some degree
but it could be extricated from that and
abstracted now we're talking about
something that is you might say closer
to home closer to actuality and Hegel
takes what is happening in the spirit
section to be tracing out the
development of human consciousness as
real actual consciousness that is what
he means by spirit
the living ethical world is spirit in
its truth when spirit first arrives at
an abstract knowledge of its essence
ethical life is submerged into in the
formal universality of legality or law
spirit which henceforth is divided
within itself traces one of its worlds
the realm of culture in the harsh
reality of its objective element over
against this realm it traces in the
element of thought the world of belief
or faith the realm of essential being
both worlds however when grasped by
spirit which after this loss of itself
withdraws into itself when grasped by
the notion are confounded and
revolutionized by the insight of the
individual and the diffusion of that
insight known as the Enlightenment and
the realm which was divided and expanded
into this world and the beyond returns
into self-consciousness which now in the
form of morality grasps itself as the
essentiality in essence as the actual
self in no longer places its world and
its ground outside of itself but lets
everything fade into itself and as
conscience is spirit that is certain of
itself
paragraph 442 should be regarded as
something like an itinerary a roadmap
for where we are going to be going in
this gigantic portion of the work spirit
you notice that it's going to culminate
in the enlightenment and morality the
enlightenment is something that we can
definitely identify with a particular
period of time we'll talk about that in
just a moment and Hegel is telling us
about how we actually get there and he
takes this as being the genuine historic
process of not just the development of
consciousness but the development of
ethical consciousness the development of
the ethical life within communities for
human beings doesn't mean that every
single human being at every single point
was you know exactly on board with the
ethical development cuz we're talking
about massive historical movements but
this this is something that we can sort
of you know retrospectively look back on
and see played out at multiple places
and times in history so he starts off by
saying the living ethical world is
spirit in its truth echoing the previous
paragraph the living ethical world the
world in which you know the the ethical
substance is not merely passive or
static but is actually doing something
there's activity there's agency there so
he says when spirit first arrives at an
abstract knowledge of its essence
remember that is the goal for spirit to
arrive at a knowledge of its very
essence now he talks first here about an
abstract knowledge of its essence and
then he talks about ethical life being
submerged in the formal universality of
legality right the firmly universality
of those Miller translated legality or
law
rekt rekt is this broad concept that
encompasses both law as what is in place
as law and the broader normativity of
legality the you know if you think about
what it means to have a law or to have a
rule or to have procedures it means that
we treat similar cases ideally as
similar to each other we generalize we
even universalize so for example when
you need a driver's license in whatever
state you happen to live in here in the
United States and it's issued by the
state and you have to jump through
certain hoops in order to get it like
showing certain documents and taking a
road test at least for the first time
and passing a written test and then when
you move from one state to another
oftentimes you have to take another
written test as I I found out like at
various driver's licenses that's a great
example of what Hegel is calling the
formal universality of legality are you
treated as the person that you are you
know in and and for yourself no no
that's not the way the law works right
formally formal universality treats
everything at a certain level in an
abstract way and there's a lot more to
it and we're going to explore that as we
we go into you know the next main
section of the work but ultimately
there's going to be some some issues
with that that is not going to be able
to capture or to adequately express the
ethical life of the community so what do
we move to next Hegel is going to
discuss two things that he calls both
realms right you know domains you could
also say he also calls these worlds so
let's look at that the pack the
paragraph now he says spirit which
henceforth is divided within itself
divided within stone
by the way because of what happens in
treating the law traces one of its
worlds the realm of culture culture is
building this is that word that doesn't
just mean culture necessarily in a very
narrow point of view but the whole broad
thing and it compasses education it
encompasses the ways in which we eat it
encompasses the language that we use
development is another way of thinking
about building as well the development
of the the person but development on a
larger scale not as a purely isolated
individual we're not just because the
laws say so but because there's some
motivating motivating ideal or a set of
ideals
so the realm of culture right spirit
traces one of its worlds the realm of
culture in the harsh reality of its
objective element he says over against
this realm now we have another over
against this realm it traces in the
element of thought the world of belief
or faith and again Miller is is
splitting up in his translation one term
globin into two different English
synonyms for it just as he did with with
cracked so globin faith belief both of
those work he is actually talking about
religious belief in this case because
what we're tracing here is the
development of human consciousness in
European history according to Hegel and
you might say well wait a second what
about the rest of the world well that's
a valid point valid worry
but Hegel is not going to be
particularly concerned with that here so
we're gonna follow along with with Hegel
so he calls this the realm of faith the
realm of essential being now notice what
he says then both worlds when grasped by
spirit which after this loss of itself
withdraws into itself when grasped by
the notion our confounded
and revolutionised Hagel uses that term
RevoluSun earrin there which is you know
essentially a loanword coming from
French talking about what the
individuals are doing when the
individual the the insight of the
individual confounds severe and
revolutionizes these worlds the world of
faith the world of culture at first this
is through individuals today writing a
book or taking a stand you might think
for example of the something that Hegel
you know thought quite a lot about the
workings of the Reformation the
Protestant Reformation in Europe did it
come about because of important social
developments that were happening you
know within within the society yes
that's certainly primed it but it did
take people like Martin Luther doing
something and sticking with doing that
something and then you know further
developments down down the line
Descartes right plenty of people were
doubting things at the time as a matter
of fact you can you can read in French
literature some of these these previous
doubters right you know Montaigne for
example Charl you know interesting
writers
however Descartes does something
different actually Descartes doesn't
really want to doubt he wants to start a
new scientific project but that that
doubting is part of how you
revolutionizes things jean-jacques
Rousseau you know both here people like
that David Hume in a certain respect are
are changing things as individuals as
are so many political leaders as are so
many other people and when that starts
to a
assume a critical mass and diffuse
itself throughout the culture and within
the realm of faith you know we often
picture that those leading the charge
against you know superstition and dogma
tis 'm were never within the church they
were these courageous outsiders
that's not the case at all if you know
your European history many of those
figures were you know people with within
the church and so what happens Hegel
says is this this with this process of
the incited individual and the diffusion
of that insight that diffusion is known
as the Enlightenment enlightenment is
the English term that we use the Germans
used a similar cognate term Alf Karim
the French speak of the C actor Lumiere
right and what are we what are we
talking about you know when we signify
say the 18th century as an age of
enlightenment we are saying that this
sort of insight of the individual is
indeed like Hegel says becoming diffused
or spreading out as I just said it's
attaining a kind of critical mass within
society people are able to communicate
with each other
there is the development of you know a
communicative sphere in coffee shops in
journals
you know rivaling the the earth earlier
realms
now what happens after that Hegel goes
on and he says the realm which was
divided and expanded into this world and
the beyond right the realm of faith was
this world and Beyond grasps is now
returning into self-consciousness which
now in the form of morality
Morales hats something that is coming
out of the the Enlightenment and we're
going to see all these projects of
practical reason to try to make sense
out of things grasps itself as the
essentiality and essence as the actual
self it no longer places its world on
its ground outside of itself but lets
everything fade into itself it becomes
the judge of everything else it
sucks everything into its own purview
and then he finishes by talking about
conscience give insight
it is spirit that is certain of itself
that is what we're driving towards in
this entire spirit section this this
process of development
the ethical world the world which is
rent asunder into this world and a
beyond and the moral view of the world
are thus the spirits whose process and
return into the simple
self-consciousness of spirit are now to
be developed the goal and outcome of
that process will appear on the scene as
the actual self-consciousness of
absolute spirit
paragraph 443 drawers this introductory
section to this massive spirit portion
of the work to a close by talking about
spirits as a plurality and talking about
how we're going to get back to spirit as
a unity or if you like as a totality so
Hegel says the ethical world is rent
asunder into this world and a beyond and
the moral view of the world
so the ethical world that we're starting
out with winds up culminating towards
the end in this realm of of faith right
globine where we have a this side and
the other side something that we've seen
already played out in the unhappy
consciousness section and which is going
to arise you know over and over again
and get fuller treatment then we have
the moral more Alicia view of the world
which is happening through the
Enlightenment and the diffusion of that
into the world of the realm the world of
faith and the world of culture in this
process Hegel says we have spirits whose
process and return into the simple
self-consciousness of spirit are now to
be developed so what we have is spirit
separating itself out into various
shapes of consciousness some of which
are going to jockey with each other or
wind up in conflict or antithesis with
each other ultimately we're aiming for
some sort of unified perspective that
brings everything back together that's
not something we can assume at the start
as a matter of fact you know we're
showing at the start that what looks
like that what looks like the ethical
life of the nation is actually breaking
up into this plurality of spirits so he
says the goal and outcome of that
process will appear on the scene and
the actual self-consciousness of
absolute spirit now that is the promise
for what we should attain in the next
two hundred and thirty-odd paragraphs
it's not something that we can begin
with it is as I said something like a
distant lighthouse whose beacon shows us
where we're supposed to be heading but
first we need to make our way through
the various shoals and reefs and and
rocks so we can get our self there and
try to avoid shipwreck or if we do have
shipwreck build a ship back up along the
way